and i don't know what's going on
are they teaching two-year-olds about
gender theory maybe i don't know there's
always one school that they find in like
san francisco
there's always one school they use as an
example
where the teachers in front of the kids
and she's like this is my labia
and tonight i'm gonna make it a [ __ ]
and your homework is to name my new car
and you go that is a bit much
that is excessive
but then like everything else in our
country it swings crazy left a crazy
right
flora's got a new bill people call it
the don't say gay bill one of the
provisions in this bill that they
dropped
was that teachers were gonna have to out
kids as gay to their parents within six
months
which is horrible
but hilarious
when you think of the calls the teachers
would have to make
hey mr morris how are you yeah
i'm todd's english teacher
yeah he's doing great no no problems
he's doing great
he is very close with another boy though
they laugh a lot they take the bus
together
oh that's his brother
okay no nothing nothing
nothing at all how are you are you good
yeah i'm just checking up on everybody
i would call i'd give it no context
hey mrs miller
your daughter's a les
let them figure it out
you know
it also makes teachers look horrible you
know
i watched your son jerk off with his
friend i think they're gay
no i did i i filmed it i knew you
wouldn't believe me
do you want to see it it's my job
no it's my job
i'm a teacher